so laila and i were working out at a on
a vacation and she brought her trx thing
it was a hotel gym and so they actually
had a trx hook so i hooked it there it
was kind of pain in the ass i'd like get
on and like put stools together it was
all the way up and i hooked it
and right as we were leaving you know
after working out i was like uh do i
want to take this with me or not like
because like no one was at the gym like
it was totally one of those like no
one's ever gonna see it yeah and so i'm
looking at this thing like it's gonna be
painting that's to get that back up get
that down and then do it again tomorrow
and the next day the next day and so i
was like well what's the upside the
upside is that i save time and effort
from doing that my downside is someone
steals it and i can't use it for the
rest of the workout and someone stole it
can i live with the downside no
okay then i have to go get it it's just
like but like that was like literally
applying yeah and i don't know if i
necessarily if i didn't have that but
sometimes applying this i was like i
can't live with the downside i'll be
really annoyed with that and the
downside is not worth it and so it
wasn't worth the upside and so it's just
applying that framework for a lot of
decisions